it took around eight hours for these
international atomic energy agency team
members to reach the saporitia region
their plan is to evaluate conditions
inside europe's largest nuclear power
plant for a few days
well we are we are a team of very
experienced people i'm bringing here
um the best of the brightest
is safeguards in safety in security and
we will have a pretty good idea
what's going on how long shelling in the
past weeks has raised concerns over the
conditions inside the plant it's a
difficult task as they will have to
evaluate the potential damage the
conditions of the personnel and whether
safety systems are in place
these will go go vadin chumack is an
expert on nuclear disasters
he says that even though the saporizia
nuclear power plant is nearly
indestructible there are many things
that could go wrong
it can be destroyed probably
only if it's a short very special
purpose with very powerful munition
so it cannot be
damaged simply because of
some occasional
bomb rocket fall nearby
the visit is taking place as ukraine is
staging a counter-offensive in the south
trying to begin what president volody
mercelenski says is the liberation of
territories occupied by russia
ukraine says its forces have destroyed
several ammunition depots and all major
bridges that will allow russian troops
to cross the diniper river everyone here
knows that this is going to be a long
fight but almost everyone is convinced
that ukraine will prevail armament not
only armor but experts like mikko
labialiskov say the offensive is a major
challenge and ukraine has bravery to
make up for the weapons it lacks the
offensive is quite a challenging scene
it's quite difficult complicated scene
you need to orchestrate the application
of
a lot of manpower a lot of equipment so
you need to to do it to have a fact you
need to to bridge the tactical depths of
defense say you need to move follow on
ashland you need to interdict the
russian possible russian
counter-moves still
as i said chances are quite high
ukraine's government continues to demand
more weapons from its western allies to
push its offensive soldiers on the front
lines are fighting to defend their
country i believe that time has come to
regain the territory they have lost
perez